Address
What's that?
A safe house.. in Paris. Why would I need a safe house in Paris? Should things at some point go terribly wrong?
It's good to have a place to go... you know ... for a cup of tea
My brothers...
My sisters, the clock is ticking faster
My dream, we who live for truth, for love
Nagini
The moment has come to take our rightful place
in the world
where we Wizards
were free
Join me
Or Die. The Wizarding and non-Wizarding worlds have been at peace for over a century
Grindelwald wants to see that peace destroyed
You want me to hunt him down
to kill him.
Dumbledore, why can't you go?
I cannot move against Grindelwald.
It has to be you
You don't suffer from motion sickness do you?
I don't do well on boats. You'll be fine.
Do you know why I admire you Nick? You do not seek power
You simply ask is the thing... right?
The time is coming
When you're going to have to pick a side
No I don't do sides.
What are you gonna do?
I'll think of something.
Newt, you never met a monster you couldn't love.
Let's take him.
That's your brother?
I think that might have been the best moment of my life